all right people
this is the reuben report direct message
i'm dave rubin
this is where we take the bananas world
and
i make it into some sort of banana cake
for you in about 24 minutes and then you
take that cake
and hopefully you serve it to other
people and the completely bananas world
is a little more digestible
in cake form or something like that
okay we're doing three stories for you
today
and one of them actually involves me
that's right i've made news or at least
something i'm in
has made news and i unfortunately don't
think it's going to surprise you
all right so the three stories that
we're going to talk about today
obviously
the big story is still the thing that
happened yesterday
that the mainstream media just does not
know how to report on
properly because it is sort of positive
to the president because
you know the middle east peace thing
which we all thought could never happen
it's kind of happening so the big story
at the moment is not just
that israel and bahrain and the united
arab emirates
sign this peace accord and there's going
to be travel and commerce and a whole
bunch of other stuff
but now uh there is a rumor and it's
just a rumor at the moment but i suspect
it's sort of a leaked rumor
kinda gonna happen that up to nine
additional nations
could join the peace deal with israel uh
including saudi arabia and this could
all happen in the next couple weeks
i said it yesterday and i'll say it
again and i'll say it again after that
this is a tectonic shift
not just in the middle east itself but
in terms of worldwide politics in terms
of alliances
in terms of the way old wars ground wars
were fought and invasions and things
like that
versus a new shifting world where people
are figuring out and countries are
figuring out how to have alliances that
are different
and maybe the old hatreds of the past
are going to be put aside
it's just an absolutely mind-blowing
story and you're not going to believe it
but the media the mainstream media yeah
they got it pretty much
all wrong all the time which is why
they're treating the story so bizarrely
right now and we're gonna play a clip
the washington beacon
put together a great compilation clip of
the pundits
and the professionals and the talking
heads just
absolutely getting everything wrong so
that is story number one
uh story number two this is probably big
too uh
i don't know if you've heard but it's
not the biden harris administration
anymore
i've been saying it wasn't the biden
administration either way and i'm still
not even
convinced that he's gonna be the nominee
at this point well i guess he's the
nominee but i'm still not convinced he's
actually
gonna make it all the way to election
day either by his own choice or
by their choice whoever they are
or by kamala's choice but twice
yesterday one time kamala
at one time joe biden actually referred
to their campaign as the
harris biden campaign
i'm not sure if you're with this but
it's actually the biden harris thing
unless they're teasing out something for
us or they're testing something
or she's as confused as he is it's all
very confusing we're going to talk about
that
and then our third story uh
and this one does involve me and it
wasn't that i was going for a story that
involves me
but i think you'll see that this is is
pretty consistent with the rest of the
nonsense that we're all dealing with
every day
uh tomorrow myself
and dennis prager and adam carolla and
ben shapiro and a couple other people
are taking uh part in something called
cancel con
and this is a live stream that we're
doing at adam corolla's studios here in
l.a where we're all going to be there in
person despite covid
we're all going to be in a room together
and we're going to be talking about the
no safe spaces movie now i'm guessing
that most of you
have seen the no the no safe spaces
movie the documentary that's all about
cancel culture
and the onslaught against free speech at
the colleges and big tech and the rest
of it
i happen to to be in a portion of the
movie uh
and we show you know what happened when
when ben went to college campuses and
they try
to burn the thing down and the rest of
it well
we're doing cancel con tomorrow couple
hour livestream i think we're doing a
four hour livestream if i'm not mistaken
uh and you're not going to believe this
but facebook has already canceled cancel
con uh that's right the guys
from cancel con have been trying to buy
ads on facebook for the last week or so
and not just a little ad not a couple
hundred bucks like major
thousands and thousands of dollars and
facebook
is refusing to put the ads up so in
essence they're canceling cancel con
uh newsweek caught wind of it and
there's a there's a big story about that
so we're gonna show you a little clip
from no safe spaces movie and then just
talk about generally how
cancel culture is not some made-up thing
even though i see a lot of people
in mainstream media telling you that
it's totally made up uh
but let's back it up and start at story
number one
all right so this idea
that not only did the united arab
emirates and bahrain sign the deal
with israel and you know these countries
have never been at war
in the sense of a traditional war they
right they haven't been launching
rockets at each other and sending ground
troops at each other but it's not even
that they were at a cold peace they were
technically
i don't think that uh bahrain or the uae
even recognized that israel existed
there was no relation so to speak
although you know one of the things that
i think is interesting right now is if
you watch the pundits
who have gotten everything wrong and
we're going to show you this great video
in just a minute
um if you only watch mainstream pundits
i think this is sort of why people are
always surprised by the news
like i wasn't totally surprised by this
peace deal because i pay attention to a
lot of other people
online and there's several people that
have been talking about this new
alliance coming around
they're not people who get mainstream
coverage just a couple names
mike duran who's a great middle east
expert who's written a couple books
and david raboy who's uh also a security
analyst and uh and a middle east expert
uh jordan shachtel a bunch of people
have been talking about how there was
going to be this gulf israel alliance
now you just never hear about that
on mainstream media and that would be if
you're a mainstream media person why
you'd be surprised when a deal like this
happens
but the idea that now nine other nations
can come in especially
saudi arabia like this is this is
massive
massive massive stuff and we can
we can unpack that all day but i thought
the media angle on this
was actually more interesting so i want
to throw to a little compilation clip
that the fine people at the washington
free beacon did because i think you'll
see that this really
sums up why so many people
who watch mainstream media have no clue
what's going on
and it'll also shed a little light on
how
people that are pundits in mainstream
media they
keep getting everything wrong and nobody
ever pays a price nobody's ever fired or
told to go home or you can't be here
anymore
or nobody's tracking any of this you did
get 27 things wrong in a row well you
happen to get one thing right
so let's keep them around let's give
them a a promotion people seem to fail
up in cable news so this is a little
compilation of cable news pundits
and other assorted personalities uh
getting everything wrong on the middle
east
by the good folks at the washington free
beacon
president trump's big decision to
recognize jerusalem as the capital of
israel and one that palestinians and
others say could destroy
hopes of middle east peace once and for
all the president's unilateral action
will get people killed
how hot will it get and how
destabilizing will it be
what he has done is thrown a diplomatic
bomb into the middle east peace process
they're not interested in history they
don't know history that would then
embarrass all the sunni arab regimes
they would have to do something
enormously complicated by the way
israel's relations with them it's going
to stop any hope of middle east
progress in the peace talks this kind of
policy unilateral decision
will basically wreck the middle east
despite warnings from turkeys president
erdogan
the kings of jordan and saudi arabia and
all of america's nato allies
that this could kill hopes for middle
east peace you'd have an explosion
an absolute explosion in the region
an absolute explosion people an absolute
explosion
bombs are going to go off wreck middle
east peace we're gonna start a war world
war iii
it's all happening i mean this is just a
tiny smattering of the types of people
that are constantly pushed out
on mainstream media to talk about a
certain narrative and they get
everything wrong what most of those
people were talking about was when trump
moved
uh the is the american embassy in israel
to jerusalem which everyone knew was
israel's capital and everyone said the
world is going to blow up if you do it
and
pretty much nothing happened there was
some protests and some rioting for about
a day
and then pretty much nothing happened
and now some other nations are doing
the same exact thing and and clearly
that somehow
started some of this reset that if you
actually do some things on the ground
you
might change the way people look at
things
so i just think it's interesting that
these people are constantly put up on
these channels
they get everything wrong they get all
their predictions wrong
and they also ratchet up i mean the
level
of rhetoric that they talk about with
these things as if they're so
certain that what they're saying is
going to happen and then it never
happens and as i said before
nobody's fired nobody's ever said you
know you as an expert i
look crunching the numbers here and your
your percentages are not that good
you're at 15 correct predictions uh we
may want to talk about that
uh there's never a price to pay and it
also it keeps everybody
thinking that war is gonna break out at
any moment
that horrible things are happening all
the time unilateral decision that must
be terrible
and it's like no and this is why and i
know this because you guys
you guys are watching this right now and
you most likely get your news from
a series of different places and
hopefully some of them are online and
podcasts and everything else
uh that you probably were not totally
surprised that this thing happened
there's a surprise i would say the
surprise is this the surprise even if
you've been tracking it isn't that it
happened i think the surprise is this
you know everyone seems to think right
now
that there's only horrible things
happening in the world and that's just
not true but the media keeps making you
think there's only horrible things but
what if the truth
hear me out on this one maybe it's a
little nutty uh what if the truth is
actually that a lot of good things are
happening
what if the truth is that peace is
actually happening and
people are realizing that decades of war
and ignoring realities no longer works
like
i kind of think that that's what's
happening here and
yes is it weird that donald trump had
something to do with it
it is kind of weird but they tried it
all the other ways right we've had
republican administrations
we've had democrat uh administrations
we've had a whole host of things
actually michael can you give me my
phone for a second i want to pull up
a tweet michael can i have my can i my
phone for just a second
michael michael michael this michael
yeah can i have my phone for a second i
want to pull up that tweet
i'm doing an impromptu pull-up of a
tweet thing i'm not even going to show
you the tweet on the screen
i'm just going to read it to you but
when you talk about pundits
kind of getting everything wrong i can't
even get in my oh man i
got my own password wrong my phone is
disabled try again in a minute i'll get
to it
in a second um but when you talk about
pundits getting
everything wrong it's like they never
pay a price for it and they also keep us
in hysteria
and that is actually the complete
reverse of what i'm going to try to do
here i still need
that one minute to back uh before i can
get to the tweet
but i'll actually i'll start giving you
a little bit on it
i saw a tweet literally right before we
started which is why we're not throwing
the image up
from david frum now david frum is a
former george w
bush uh campaign speechwriter and
advisor he's the guy that came
up with the phrase axis of evil and as
you probably
remember the phrase axis of evil
uh is the phrase that george w bush used
in his big speech that basically pushed
us
towards the iraq war that most people
think was a complete disaster that is
david frum's line
i've had him on the show i think he's a
perfectly
fine human being but he's one of these
people that no matter what
trump does that is objectively good
peace is good they always figure out a
way to spin it into something negative i
think this is
this is a real issue that we've got with
the pundit class
and i got it here i got it uh so he just
tweeted this out i saw it literally
right before we started and i think this
just kind of
like sums it up this is a guy who again
wrote the speech that got us into the
iraq war how many people died in the
iraq war someone can fact check me it's
something like 400
000 people uh his tweet a minute ago
trump administration's middle east peace
efforts somewhat diminished by trump
administration
recklessly exposing the leaders who
signed the peace
to a potentially lethal infection
so he's trying to make this thing about
coronavirus which by the way uh
cnn during their their chiron their
headline on this
yesterday there's an incredible clip
you've probably seen it on twitter
where they show the white house and
there's all the leaders up there right
the leaders from all the different
countries they're signing this thing
cnn instead of saying you know peace
deal historic peace deal sign or
something their bottom chiron says
something like
um not as men
uh audience not wearing masks at white
house event
something to that effect whitehead it
was just a white house it meant
and they make it about the mask thing
but but the fact is like someone like
this
who gets everything wrong and has gotten
everything wrong
for decades helped lead us into wars
um they can't even give credit where
credit's due i would think someone like
you might want peace in the middle east
but what you'd rather do
is make it seem like someone's gonna get
covered at the freaking white house
uh peace signing ceremony it's just such
drivel i'm so tired you know what hold
me to a higher standard guys if i start
getting everything wrong i've had a
pretty freaking good
track record right like a lot of the
lunacy going on in the world right now i
think i've been one of the guys ahead of
it right i've been talking about this
stuff
for five years and talking about why
identity politics is evil
and what's happening to the left and
then the growing threat of socialism and
freezing
free speech and all of these things and
i even
i was sort of basically saying trump's
gonna win uh
you know last time like um and i didn't
even vote for the guy like i've had a
pretty good track record i don't think
you're gonna find
major instances where i consistently
over a long period of time got things
wrong
but if i start getting everything wrong
i think you will probably hold me to
account you know how you do it you'll
probably stop
watching and uh that's probably what you
should be doing
on on some of these cable news channels
as well all right the next story
oh lord joe joe joe joe joe it's just
getting sad i mean yesterday it was just
like clip after clip after clip going
viral of biden just screwing things up
did you see the clip of him talking
about
the quartermaster on the second floor
and go to the women's department or the
ladies department it's like nobody knows
what the guy's talking about anymore
but putting aside all the verbal gaffes
and and the confusion and
all of that kind of stuff um both
joe biden and his vice presidential
candidate
uh kamala kamala kamala harris
they both made bizarre statements
yesterday
we looped them together here and i
believe this is harris first
and you tell me what's wrong with these
statements here we go
a harris administration together with
joe biden
harris biden administration is going to
relaunch that effort and keep pushing
further
a harris administration with joe biden
that was kamala right there
and i think we do have the clip of joe
making the exact
same error oh we did joe right there
okay
so joe and kamala
are both calling this a harris biden
administration now
uh as you guys know i've been saying for
about six months that if you're a
democrat
let's say you're a democrat you're a
regular democrat
you're a far lefty you're a progressive
whatever you are you're someone voting
for biden
you're not even a democrat you're just
someone who hates trump so you're gonna
vote for biden
you must know at this point that a vote
for biden
is a vote for his vp it didn't matter
who the vp was going to be
but biden will obviously not be in
obvious it is depressing and by the way
one of the things that i've been
thinking about lately is
because i keep saying that the scandal
is the non-scandal meaning i don't think
the scandal is that he has dementia or
that something's cognitively wrong with
him that that's unfortunate and it's and
it's sad
and should be dealt with and i hope he
gets the help that he needs but the
scandal really that that's like the mini
scandal here because that we can all see
the scandal is that they're pretending
there's no scandal and that then
really shines the light on what's going
on with the dnc and who's ever pulling
the
the levers of power and the way the
media covers for it and everything else
and i was thinking about this yesterday
you know the more obvious it becomes
over the next six weeks and especially
when we get to the debates
that something really is not right with
biden when the scandal breaks
i wonder i think this thing could take
down the entire party and even more than
the party like
even hillary clinton barack obama
they have to know something is not right
here and it has to have been discussed
with them right like they're the they're
the elders of the party
um i don't think that that obama
realizes how how far on the outs of the
future of the party he is because
they're going to go way too radical
either for him and the whole point of
the new radicals is if everything was
racist and evil before you well obama
was part of that for eight years and he
didn't fix it
so they're going to take out obama too
but when the scandal actually breaks
like you got to think this thing's going
to
they'll all turn on each other and blame
everybody else like oh i knew and i
wanted to say something i knew and i
wanted to say something
and everyone's gonna turn on each other
but then what is the duty i mean
this really is what i was thinking
yesterday what is the duty
of hillary clinton or
more importantly barack obama because he
was the president of the united states
and he's sort of
the he's sort of the figurehead for the
party even if
he maybe isn't that involved in the dnc
directly
like barack obama knows something's up
he does barack if you're watching we
know you know
i don't mean to be a dick but we know
you know and it's like what
responsibility do these people have to
america
to the country if they're backing
someone who clearly
is having cognitive problems so when
when biden and harris both say
a harris biden administration that is
possibly a verbal gaffe but it might
also be a tip-off
like a subtle off to we know this thing
ain't right
now now the interesting thing is when
they say
uh harris biden if biden was to step
down it's not that he would step down to
be
vp again he would step down to disappear
right and i think that's going to happen
probably pretty quickly
the question is then who does harris
bring in and what i would really fear
and i think this was the trojan horse
the
idea the whole time is that they're
going to smuggle biden and i think the
plan was smuggled item in then we get
you know one of our more radical lefties
so that's harris
but then what comes after that is once
we get biden out now harris is president
and we bring in
really one of the bananas lefties you
know someone out of the out of the
bernie playbook
so anyone voting for biden especially if
you're voting for biden just because you
think he's the last stand
against the crazies in the party just
understand you're you're missing the
boat here your
your aim is off you're looking in the
wrong direction
as they're playing a shell game and and
you better wake up to it so
there's just been a lot of that and i'll
just throw in one more clip here because
as i said yesterday was just like an
endless gaff clip with biden and biden
was speaking at a latino
i'm gonna say latino i know they like to
say latinx even though no latino person
says latinx
he was speaking at a latino democrat
event
and well here's what he did
i just have one thing to say
they're going here
[Music]
i'll tell you what if i had the talent
of any one of these people i'd be
i'd be elected president by acclamation
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you
oh oh joe oh joe the pandering
the cringe all of it i mean
how is trump more authentic than all of
these people it doesn't make any
freaking sense
just like that to go up there and play
it's a justin bieber song despacito
which i was away last summer and i was
at this uh
resort and they played literally like 10
times an hour and i almost killed
somebody i actually almost killed
the guy that was bringing us drinks at
the pool i couldn't take it anymore it
wasn't his fault but i was i was
you hear that song enough it's enough
you know anyway
the pandering to just walk up there
playing that it's like whose idea
is this stiff ridiculousness and that's
why when trump just goes up there and
says whatever he's thinking it's like it
may be
slightly crazy and it may be off the
cuff and his inflection's a little weird
and he changes
thoughts in the middle of a sentence and
everything else but it's more authentic
than this stiff thing
joe or it's like they're sitting there
there's like a group of people and
they're sitting there and they're going
we've got to get joe biden to seem
relatable
to latino people or they probably say
latinx people we need to get latinx
people on board the biden
train what can we do should should we
have a meet a taco out there well
you know trump took that picture with
the taco bell that seemed to work well
and they were like no no no no let's get
him to play desposito
by justin bieber who's white i mean it's
all just so
stupid just so stupid all right guys one
more for you
facebook have you heard of this thing
it's a giant big tech company that owns
all of your information and owns your
children
and is trying to destroy you um they are
canceling cancel con so if you don't
know what cancel con is cancel con is an
event
that uh dennis prager ben shapiro adam
carolla
myself and a couple other people are
doing tomorrow we're doing a live stream
at adam's studio here in la and it's to
promote the no safe spaces documentary i
hope that you guys have seen the no safe
spaces documentary uh i happen to be in
it but
but but putting aside that i'm in it it
truly
is a wonderful powerful painful
funny super interesting incisive
documentary about the state of cancer
culture what's happening on college
campuses
and everything else we're gonna just
play a quick little promo clip from
the no safe spaces they're not they're
not paying us for this or anything else
like that
uh but i just wanna show you a quick
clip of what it is
that facebook is now trying to cancel so
here's a quick promo
[Music]
this is brand new this is one of the few
things one could say
we have no precedent for in the united
states how long before they come for
your job
and for my job it will come for you if
you have anything about you that's
interesting or different
they will come to destroy that too
all right so that that's just a tiny
clip of the no safe spaces movie it
really is fantastic they talk about the
jordan peterson ex
uh issues related to you know people
attacking him and
protesting and the rest of it uh big big
segment uh with brett weinstein and a
couple other people
okay so we're doing this cancel account
event tomorrow to promote
the movie that's what you do and the
people behind the movie the producers
have decided to put a little
money into advertising the movie again
this is what you do
you do this on social media so they were
putting thousands of dollars or they
wanted to put
thousands of dollars behind the movie to
promote it and facebook is refusing to
let
them put ads um now this is
obviously political and it proves the
very
thesis of the documentary that facebook
doesn't want you to see
this is very much in line when uh when
don't burn this book came out
and the idea behind the title was that
you don't want to burn books right and
that's what they did in nazi germany you
don't want to burn books
and then all of these you know reddit
losers
they all coordinated to attack the
amazon reviews of the book and they had
never read the book obviously
and in essence that's a digital book
burning
right when you try to why would you put
bad reviews for a book you've never read
well it's because you don't want other
people to read it that's the same reason
you burn a book
and this is the same sort of thing the
movie is about stopping cancel culture
and facebook is trying to cancel it so
it's obviously personal to me but i know
it's an important issue to any of you
guys that are watching this as well
and uh look big tech it's not going to
get better
it's just not going to get better
twitter's not going to get better
facebook is not going to get better
youtube is not going to get better the
way they treat us and the shadow
bannings
and the de-boosting and everything else
they're features not
bugs we can complain about it the lord
knows i do complain about it
but you got to take charge of your take
charge your digital life that's actually
why i started locals.com but that's a
whole other
a whole other topic all together in any
event
uh you guys tomorrow uh can watch
me shapiro prager corolla all over at
corolla studio which is a pretty great
spot um
and we're going to be streaming it on
the young americans for freedom
uh youtube page and facebook page and
the rest of it and we we interviewed a
couple other people in advance i talked
to
former wisconsin governor scott walker
and it's going to be fun
and it's going to be different and we're
going to stick it to youtube because
they deserve to get it stuck to
all right that is the reuben report
direct message
and get out there and save the country
people
no one else is going to do it it's on
you you've got work to do
i'll see you tomorrow